[Music]
this is burj khalifa the tallest
building in the world
this masterpiece in dubai is twice the
height of the us's empire state building
and it's almost three times the size of
the eiffel tower
so
what if you took a tumble from the top
how could you slow your fall
would anybody be able to catch you on
the ground
and why does g-force matter
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell off the world's
tallest building
if you fell three stories
your chance of dying would be 50 percent
if you fell more than 10 stories
you'd have a very slim chance of
surviving
the burj khalifa is
160 stories high
and now you're falling off of it
that would be a long way down but
a longer distance means you'd have more
time to react
would there be anything you could do to
save yourself
the reason you plummet to the ground
when you fall off a building
is because of gravity everything in the
universe has gravity
even you
and since gravity increases with mass
the earth has a larger gravitational
force than you do
so you're falling toward the center of
the earth but you don't fall at a
constant speed
the pull of earth's gravity makes you
accelerate every second that you're
free-falling
that is until you reach the maximum
speed of your fall called the terminal
velocity
then the air resistance will push back
against earth's gravity
you'd still be falling but you'd stop
accelerating and it's essential to know
about terminal velocity because
it might just save your life
when skydivers want to fall fast they
pull in their arms and legs to make
themselves as small as possible
in this position they can reach a
maximum speed of
290 kilometers per hour
but if you want to slow your fall you'd
stretch out your arms and legs
this would create more drag and more air
resistance
when skydivers do this they can slow
their maximum speed to 200 kilometers
per hour
but you're not a skydiver so you'd
probably reach a terminal velocity of
about 240 kilometers per hour after
5.7 seconds of your fall
and for the next 12 seconds you'd be
plummeting toward the ground at 240
kilometers per hour
that's faster than your car goes on a
highway
and it's not the speed alone that would
kill you when you hit the ground
the real killer is how fast you'd go
from traveling at high velocity
to a standstill
okay let's talk physics g-force is the
force of acceleration on your body
the quicker you go from a high velocity
to no velocity the stronger the g-force
you'd experience
while you're falling through the air
you'd feel the force of one g as one g
is equal to the acceleration caused by
earth's gravity
but when you suddenly stop falling
because
you hit the ground
you wouldn't have any time to decelerate
that instant change from high to low
velocity would create a g-force
stronger than your body could take
this is why landing on a soft surface
increases your chance of survival
if you land in snow or fall through some
trees
it would slow your descent increasing
your stopping time and that would lower
the g-force meaning less damage to you
but it doesn't snow in dubai and the the
only trees around are palm trees
they don't have enough branches to slow
your fall and even if someone caught you
they'd only slow your fall by
0.06 seconds
that wouldn't be enough to save you but
it would seriously hurt the person
catching you
so if you have a long way to fall like
off the top of the burj khalifa
there would be no way you could land
safely
unless maybe instead of hitting the
ground you just continued falling all
the way through the earth
would you come out the other side
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you